[ Cheers and applause ]
-These are two of our writers,
everybody.
That´s Amber and that´s Jenny.
-I´m black.
-And I´m gay.
-And we´re both women.
-And I´m not.
So, here´s how this works.
I´ll read the setups
for these jokes
and Amber and Jenny will read
the punch lines, here goes.
Starbucks recently hired its
first black female C.O.O.
-Or as her coworkers call her,
Venti Cocoa Mochaccino.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It was announced recently
that the upcoming lesbian reboot
of the show,
"Xena, Warrior Princess"
has been canceled.
-So if you want to watch
a show for lesbians,
you´ll have to watch
"Monday Night Football."
[ Audience groans ]
-And, Jenny --
Jenny, do you like football?
-Ugh, No.
If I want to see someone wearing
a bunch of pads, I´ll go to
a Natalie Merchant concert
during a full moon.
-Whose Natalie merchant?
-Oh, I can take this.
She´s who you played
when you wanted to make out
with a girl in 1993.
-Did it work?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Former White House
Communications Director
Anthony Scaramucci reportedly
has a minority stake
in the New York Mets.
-Coincidentally, minority steak
is what Donald Trump calls
barbecued ribs.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-San Francisco was
recently named
the most popular destination
for gay people.
-While the most popular
destination
for closeted gay people
is the Vatican.
-Oh.
[ Audience gasps ]
[ Applause ]
I -- I didn´t know that.
-It´s true.
Hey, Seth, you know
what lesbians and nuns
have in common?
-What?
-They´re lesbians.
-Huh.
[ Light laughter ]
A rare white lobster was caught
recently in the Gulf of Maine.
-But since it was white,
it got to live.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Several conservatives have
suggested that Hurricane Harvey
was God´s punishment for Houston
electing a lesbian mayor.
-That´s ridiculous.
If God wanted
to punish a lesbian,
He´d make her a bridesmaid.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-A University of Memphis
police officer is suing
the school for
reverse discrimination.
-Reverse discrimination is
like regular discrimination,
except it doesn´t exist.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A group of parents
in an Alabama school
recently started a petition
to have the rainbow flag
outside a teacher´s
classroom taken down,
saying it´s the same
as the Confederate flag.
-And it is, except the gays won.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
Whoa, daddy!
Aah!
Hey, Seth,
why don´t you tell one?
-No I couldn´t, you guys.
-Oh, come on, just one.
-No, I feel like if I do
I´ll get in trouble,
and it won´t end well.
-Please, Seth, please.
-Come on, buddy.
-Yeah!
-Do it! Do it!
-Do it, Seth!
-Do it!
-Okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
They´re so behind me,
I´ll never lose them.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Scotch Day.
"I´ll have two fingers,"
said lesbians.
-Seth, no!
-Where did all the applause go?
[ Light laughter ]
-Seth!
-You told me it would be okay!
-Very bad.
-Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, I´m sorry.
Let me try another one.
-Okay.
[ Light laughter ]
-New York´s Lincoln Center
recently hosted
a national Double-Dutch
competition and the winner was,
I´m guessing, black.
[ Light laughter ]
-How dare you?
-You should be ashamed
of yourself!
-Well, were they?
-Yes, they were.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We´ll be right back with more
"Late Night" everybody.